robert spencer as basically america's
expert on islam
what would you recommend to our viewers
what is the best book to learn about
islam you had one time talked about nj
dawood's book uh it's the best
translation but you've got some stuff
out now too recommend a source to our
viewers so they can learn a little bit
about what you know
barry i do have a book coming out in may
called the critical quran which is an
honest translation of the quran that
makes clear what it says all too many
translations of the quran into english
actually try to obscure what it really
means but the critical quran contains an
honest and clear translation plus
commentary to show how mainstream
islamic authorities understand the
various passages so you'll see why there
is justification for terrorism for
spousal abuse
for
all manner of things that we see in the
islamic world it's all explained in the
critical quran
then i
should also mention my book the history
of jihad from a couple years back that
is the only history of jihad that covers
the phenomenon entirely from the
beginning to today
and i think that book would open a lot
of people's eyes they don't realize what
has been going on all around the world
all this time and this is a history that
is not being taught in schools